[Applaudissements]
et en direct et merci de faire que tous
les soirs touche pas à mon poste et le
premier tokyo de profs merci les six
régates et être aussi nombreux à nous
regarder
vous l'avez entendu on a mis une
deuxième musique après la pub à dos mais
à chaque fois depuis
non mais c'est bon on s'en fout de vous
les housses là quand même
http je vous dit quel est le point
commun entre les trois musiques qu'on va
passer ce soir il y en aura une
troisième tout à l'heure après la
prochaine coupure j'aime beaucoup ce
balayage jeudi à des avants postes
médiatiques et un balayage qui est très
belle
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement ce qu'un balayage que je
ne peux plus faire puisque j'ai eu
facile quand même quasiment les cheveux
très très très blanc d'un hommage à quai
sturm mêmes parce que tu sais pourquoi
ça adoucit ferait s'est adoucie et
quelque chose ouais j'suis en
adoucissant la randonnée nord sur les
trop conseiller aux dons je parle pas de
notre ami là où c'est désastreux mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme moi des crosnes blonde c'est
impossible c'est ça